chucky episode three today guys you know
the drill subscribe and hit that
notification really get notified when i
reaction for the next one is up been
enjoying this series so much hit that
like button that's actually the most
important thing you can do full length
watch as long as we sync up with the
time code they're at our patreon page
covers so many other shows over there
reaction highlights included for a lot
of them very chronic thanks for writing
these down i think you're doing a good
job we're stack shooting them so we'll
see
[Music]
how did you end up like this
in a lot of ways it was your standard
voodoo soul transfer no i mean
how did you become a killer
first place
oh i get it all right kid
let me tell you the story of my first
time oh god here we go
i really want to see chucky versus
michael myers
[Music]
that's cool they changed the intro every
time yeah it's clever everywhere jake
wheeler goes
death seems to follow i think jake knows
more than he's saying i'm sorry i can't
help you can't
or won't
well which one is it
that's our baby
i'm sorry i had to see that all right i
can't imagine how much that hurt i wish
i could like
kiss you never mind no it's stupid
just hug you back to feeling good i wish
i could like
protect you or something oh
[Laughter]
i can't believe she did that it must
have been so angry
of course i was angry you know lexi can
be a real [ __ ]
you know what she's like
no but she was just messing around
oh i gotta go do a project
homework
and see you later i don't know
i mean baby
yes see you devon
i saw the pictures from oliver's party
they're all over school
i screenshot and save it to my phone
and i sent him to all the staff
i just want you to know that you can
always come to me yeah
you can trust me oh you're dead lady i
like her but you know she's dead
yeah we get to know you
what they like
where they go oh [ __ ]
but eventually
you gotta get your victim alone
oh no oh god dude oh no
this is truly chilling
what the hell are you doing
i i wasn't doing anything i was it was
such a problem
the right moment always comes
man
yeah that's chilling
oh my god why is she acting like this
i got her a doll no she likes her
blankie no no you're hey hey what can i
get you
chucky's my best
[Music]
yeah go running with that yes
that's
so embarrassing
oh my god
no the attacks do a wax museum once
totally sucked
probably the same tools in the wall just
like this one
this is actually pretty cool
why are you even here i'm here because i
need to talk to you
if you can fit me into your busy
gardening
schedule gotta hate her
you can't even ingratiate yourself
properly
dead dad halloween costume thing
i guess i can sort of see why you'd take
that the wrong way
there was a right way look i'm sorry
[Music]
i hurt your feelings
i'm sure you want to know what you can
do for me
hey lexi
what could i do for you
not for me i think he's totally creepy
for caroline
no no no absolutely not no
you can never have him you mean i came
all the way here to apologize and this
is how you repay me yeah that's exactly
how
yeah
yeah
oh
called completion anxiety
look i wanted to do it
let me fix your lexi problem
how
by caleb we give her what she wants
we should collab with this guy
definitely
he is doing the detective work no
i need to talk to you about jake
what about jake
i think it's best if you stay away from
him from now on jake's dad died and now
you're making jake the bad guy this
isn't about jake's dad this is about my
son
yeah this feels very caring
this kid's so good man
i know
it's an edict
stay away from him
why'd you tell him to eat a dick
[Laughter]
sometimes you just gotta let your kid
know man we gotta lay down the law
where are you here
i just
i thought it was cool of you to
apologize the way you did i know
chucky's
chucky
she can
oh damn he's an accomplice yeah
absolutely
it's like birth of a dexter vibe yeah
great that's a little genius doing that
[ __ ]
i like to be hugged
she's so smart
no i just whispers right for them
[Music]
[Laughter]
we're really breaking through with her
hey
sorry it took forever full time to leave
how long don't you know
we believe that bullying is unacceptable
as do we
it's come to our attention that lexi has
been bullying jake
our daughter is not the bully if
anything she's the victim did you see
what that kid did at the talent show he
humiliated her jake's been through a lot
lately that is not an excuse for his
behavior tell him about the costume a
student brought this to my attention
oh damn
that's gotta hurt
i'm gonna see that too i thought they
were aware for some reason yeah
my brother
i think we can all agree the best thing
is to go home talk to your kids
find a way to move forward
what up
strong parent teacher conference
hey man in the day and age of cell phone
footage i bet they've gotten a lot more
efficient meetings over just uh go home
and talk to them go deal with it
now you know what you need to know
we showed you the video we're not going
to talk strategy or
possible ways you can go about this
we're not their parents man we don't
need to get into that go to sleep you
didn't do it right
bedtime you have to sing to me daddy
sings to me if you tell anyone about
this
i'll kill you
i won't say a word
oh my god this is going to be
humiliating for you
so embarrassing you bust out your
professional singing voice
come on baby don't fear the reaper
that
surprisingly was
effective
like that's a silly choice oh never mind
compelled all of a sudden
hey kid
i'm gonna go kill your sister
are you sleepy
oh no oh snug is a [ __ ] bug
a little weighted blanket
chucky's gone
are you sure maybe he fell into your bed
he said he's going to kill you
caroline why would you say that
come on
whoo i'm kind of scared
[Laughter]
oh wow
oh
holy moly
hey lexie
oh
what
my bad
oh they all have headphones on yeah
that's an interesting theme of traumatic
recreation that i did not expect from
this [ __ ]
meanwhile in the eyes wide shut room
this is
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh god
oh
jake
you
[Laughter]
holy crap
no
is it over oh thank god
i'm not ready for it to be done
oh i had a feeling he would do it yep
you got guts kid
i'll give you that
you've got to cover your tracks
some killers are made but the best of us
are born
bastards
yeah give me more
itchiness
give
[ __ ]
that was um that was an intense one yeah
that was
genuinely like
fraught yeah we're scripting
gripping and fraud are two good words
for that
very good words for that it was like
almost like the edge of my seed right
now which is like the biggest surprise
maybe of all like i i've been enjoying
it i expected to enjoy it but they've
consistently
given me
us
both exactly what i expected but also
something
that feels like it has a lot more at the
core than what i expected yeah you know
especially when watching the three back
to back you're watching the evolution
like the first episode kind of plugs you
into something much more familiar
and now they're getting
deeper and more creative
and truly like
like uh
an uncomfortable
sinister
like
she feels like real like menacing yeah
and uh
yeah and the way they're like utilizing
the the spare use of his flashbacks to
charles lee ray's upbringing
and i like how they kept it
that he's still just born a killer like
if anything he found inspiration from
seeing the murderer not
like oh my god i'm [ __ ] up and now i'm
creating that no it's like he found the
missing piece of what to do with these
feelings yeah yeah it's it's it's
different it's very different
and uh how they've been flushing out
like chic ducky what was her name lexi
next alexia so like oh god she is just
so awful
uh she is
but the scene's so suspenseful in the
way they
the way they draw the tension in
in the whole sequence in the house was
so well done that you find yourself like
a little little scared right now even
though i technically don't really like
this girl i'm a little scared
i'm fascinated by the the blend of
character tones they've drawn especially
with her because in this episode they
skated what i think is a razor thin line
between
having her be
this hateable almost i mean tropey
character but then also adding layers on
to where you don't necessarily like her
or even want her to live but you are
like i kind of get what your life is
like and why you're this way
and now i
don't as gleefully want to see you die
like like there's yes that's the best
way to put it it's like it's not as
yeah it's not it's not as much of a
celebration of her dying yeah because
they haven't really done anything to
make her likeable
but they've done things to make her go i
guess you're not
as bad
yeah they've done some subtle things and
show it like like you know and
developing like okay what her home life
is like and i thought like her apology
scene as much as there are elements of
her like immediately returning to
insults that maybe undermine some of
that i did think the apology was was
like a nice you could watch her layers
almost breaking apart for like a hot
second as she actually gets a little
vulnerable with him before covering
right back up
yes
i suppose so it still pissed me off so
much oh absolutely it's still such a
[ __ ]
it's like i rarely use that word for
anybody but she it's like it's your ass
like it is that thing of like you must
be asking for it because you can't even
do this in a way where you're not being
a complete [ __ ] about it and like
making it all about you and like how you
must feel the need to pay me back for
this i'm so humble yeah
it's like a lonely island moment
and
it's kind of like it's weird because
it's it's a little manipulative of what
they did in the moment
it's manipulative in a way that i admire
um
when she's dancing with oliver yeah
and then
you're like okay here's this she's gonna
flat out cheat out cheat on him
and then she
gets a song comes on that she really
loves and so she wants to dance with uh
junior cousin junior yeah she wants to
dance for junior
and at that moment it's like
it's not like she did something likeable
it's that oh you didn't do something as
bad as i thought you like i'm surprised
you went to your boyfriend it's they
they're great at catching you off guard
with character beats that that like oh
she might actually like him they play
against i think the the
you know the way we profile these
characters in slasher things and root
for them to die like i think they're
good at playing on those actual
character elements i think what they've
implemented with her are a little bit
more subtle in the sense of they
they i think one thing though i mean if
there's something that they've done to
show her heart
is that
she cares about her younger sister
clearly as much as she is like jealous
of the attention that she gets she also
seems to be the only one truly
trying to hone into
her actual emotions like she needs the
blanket or the sunglasses or something
and she sits down and goes what do you
actually want and it seems like she
apologized
forced herself through that moment just
to get the chucky doll yeah
um
yeah but then it like puts a challenging
position for our main character because
oh that was
either like a straight up was like go
kill you know yeah
yeah and i mean that whole scene where
he drops the doll off and the girl comes
out like in the just the play of
emotions across that was great yeah
that's my math i like i really admire
that they they made it that they let
their main character do that that it
wasn't just chuck because i feel like in
the a lot of movies and stuff or even
like the earlier child's play films if
it would be a case of just chucky ghosts
does this thing yeah but he made the
choice to
be like i can't do the final kill so
you do it yeah i tried and i know that i
can't but i'll put you in the position
oh man so yeah that's a challenge it's
like it's a it's a it's a challenge that
can make your main character unlikable
absolutely yeah and it's also one of
those things where
you know and there are uh
depictions of high schoolers that are
very over the top in the show especially
with how like at the party not a single
person objects everyone thinks you know
her dressing as his dead dad is funny
like that's a little over the top but um
when it came to um
oh goodness my train of thought uh when
it came to yeah when it comes to like
those um
teen
it's it's i believed that you could find
yourself in that position basically
where you are so hurt and you're so
alienated that you're like you know what
uh yeah i'll i'll take this
i'm not gonna do it myself i'm too
afraid to do it but i have the means so
i'll just i'll just
let the means do their thing like it's
this decision i could see somebody in
that position making and then you know
when he's in the cemetery over his
parents graves
hearing the scions realizing the reality
then being like oh google what have i
done yeah you know like i could see that
in a more um
in what felt like a more natural way
like i thought they played that in a way
that felt grounded almost
the way the way they use their they
can't though the use of camera is so
impressive
yeah i love that shot where it looks
like a just a a moving shot and then low
tracking yeah and then the way it pulls
like oh we're in a pov yeah so clever
yeah and and uh
the the the aesthetic that they choose
with
um the flashbacks and stuff with the
what do you call that frame you
it's like eight millimeter film yeah
it's like a it's like a three by four
frame
well with using the music and the era
you get almost this born the devil kind
of vibe with him you know like i'm
almost like a manson vibe yeah
yeah and then like engulfed in the
flames with that shot like this is for
jake and then it's just he's laughing
maniacally like
a devil in hell
you know seven minutes in hell
and then the way like they killed oliver
too man he did not put up a fight back
on that guy no she put up a hell of a
fight yeah
i think i think there is a shock factor
that comes to realizing like that holds
a lot of that because i thought they
handled that well
with her because she's fighting back the
whole time and but then she like starts
to cower with the reality she realizes
oh this is this is a supernatural
happening right now
and that's a great and that's a great
line too is yeah there's something about
like being strangled from behind while
i'm sure your mind is everywhere it's
still like there's a level of
tangibility where you must understand
the situation in your head and then yeah
when you make the realization that it's
another caliber scarier yeah it was a
great moment that i don't know if i've
ever seen a horror movie actually quite
do well they i think that's what through
through them off especially with oliver
like i think it's why oliver didn't
fight back because he was just so like
shocked
yeah
i mean that's the other thing like there
is
the thing there are many things that are
really effective about chuckie and i
feel like it's probably the key to why
chucky has been able to survive so many
different
tones levels of quality etc because
there's something inherently scary about
just leaving your kid alone with a
possessed doll there's also something
inherently scary about anybody
encountering a doll that's like two feet
tall and has is trying to actively
murder you like they would just it's
yeah it would disconcert you on a whole
other level this has this has incredible
camera work like the framing devices
they use are solid they do such a great
job with
like their backgrounds and knowing
where to center their characters and
positions that have like an artistic
representation with the background it's
really it's surprisingly impressive and
i love how the show started off on this
like
campy
level not too campy i'm not gonna say
like full camp but it was heightened for
sure and then it's
really
become more
effective in a horror tense way yeah
and
it's becoming what okay i think what it
is is that it starts off with the chucky
world
doll kills and now it's going into
that real uncomfortable feeling of
watching serial killer activity you know
yeah and watching yeah true cruelty
because i think you call it carrie and
that's a great touchstone actually right
because
yeah it's like the true extent of
cruelty and then real deranged serial
kill like when he's stalking her out
when she's running like yeah that is
like really uncomfortable and it's like
you're watching
i like that it's asking and probing at
like what creates the serial killer
without fully going it's this you know
it's like here's what happened to
charles lee ray i'd be curious to know
it i feel like like my reception of
these scenes is pretty positive but i
also like the flashbacks of the rob
zombie movie which a lot of fans don't
so i'd be curious to know what fans
think of that but it feels like
it's a solid
just view in on the origins of that
character without feeling like this is
how evil is created
you know
i mean i think
without diving too much into it and we
just touch on for like 30 seconds
there's a big difference though when
you're michael myers the whole point is
he's he's mute yeah he's a shape
whereas
people know this is charles lee ray
yeah chuckie sure for sure and and when
he's introduced in in child's play you
see him as brad doroth first before he
transforms into the doll or puts his
soul on the doll so
um
yeah it's i think it lends itself a
little bit more to
see a little bit about his background
versus like where michael myers the
whole point is the mystique yeah
yeah
because you said something about about
chucky versus michael myers and michael
is a character i've never actually
wanted to see in a versus movie because
i don't think it works wouldn't it be
great but i would actually if there's
any character because i think you could
just play on the complete tonal
separation of that yeah it would be the
freddie versus jason did anybody use
that with
yeah it's the only character i could see
that with but but but also to
just another layer of goodness i thought
this episode did was they've done so
much with jake about like well he's got
to be a common denominator in these
murders somehow uh but then in this
episode you've got the party going on
and you did they did a number of shots
just looking at other characters clearly
having feelings about what's going on
with different characters and sort of
showing
kind of the potential for anybody who is
you know
he's showing the motivation that could
get muddy here
yeah for you know people's jealousy and
anger and hurt and frustration and all
sorts of stuff that leads people down
these darker more visceral paths i think
what this show does well is it it shu
they let the truth
the truth of what's going on with the
characters rests on their faces
when they're alone
like alone alone in thought yeah
i mean you see it right there even in
the scene with jake when he is
um
uh man i wish more people stuck around
for our review so sometimes i feel like
we say some cool stuff sometimes i feel
like we'd give up a solid ass review
let's start putting these up as podcasts
on just the auditory platforms let's see
if maybe more people listen
the the
it's
like when he's talking with um
damn what's her name lexi lexi he's
talking with lexi
and
whenever her back is turned he's
like filled with like i want to kill her
like that that darkness in him
but then when he faces her it fetches
and you see that a lot more with like
the looks when they let the camera
linger on lexi when she's more alone in
her thoughts not so much when she's
interacting with people
uh less of the veneer and more of just
the reality of what the vulnerable
situation she's in
even with the cousin too you know like
he had a bit of a vulnerable moment like
yeah when he's like watching her dance
with all of her yeah yeah you know
people they let them you know it in
devon in the podcast room and stuff and
that kid is such a great so good he's so
good yeah he has that like believable
mature kid yeah not like
weird actor trained child who would like
be an adult you know yeah
he has
a believable mature kid quality to
himself yeah really like and and being
the son of yeah detective it's like all
the character pieces that could just
play as this is a character we cobbled
together out of modern stuff people like
podcasts true crime you know he's
one thought he was going to be yeah yeah
yeah and then you're like well okay it
seems like it's just you and your mom
and it seems like you probably would
have to grow up kind of fast and and
also yeah you've got this secret that
you're harboring that clearly you and
your mom aren't fully talking about yet
and what seeing the way his relationship
is with his mom it
complements why he would be so mature
and eloquent
and uh uh
empathetic and understanding what's
going on yeah exactly
it does a great job at fleshing out the
character dynamics
which is the last thing you expected to
talk about during the chucky show
which is but that's what makes good
horrors like it's it can have all the
camp and schlock but also it rests it on
these character bits like it's
implemented there in the first ep it's
there in the first episode but it
doesn't feel as like
richly nuanced but then as the show's
progressing it's becoming more nuanced
and and i don't know maybe
it's impressive it is impressive like i
was i was really really engrossed in
this and this in a suspenseful way like
this is not funny
yeah
and i like
i like especially when things that are
supposed to be funny part of the time
can get to that place where this part is
not funny yeah you know that like
there's some deaths and aspects of the
macabre humor that you know are very
much that lurid comedy but also there
are some that yeah just wants you to
feel uncomfortable
i appreciate that
all right guys well
three chucky episodes down
leave your thoughts down below
um in real time i'm filming this there's
one only one more episode out and then
gotta catch up to the fifth this is
really enjoyable i'm having a blast i
can shoot these all night this is
seriously like really enjoyable yeah
this is probably the the most just like
instantly i'm sucked in i'm having a
great time i can't wait to watch the
next one like i i
i'm noticing all these things but also
it's just flying by because i'm so
wrapped up in it like i'm i'm very
jazzed right now yeah thank god we
started this my goodness
um all right well thanks for being here
and uh
let's do a paper
scooby-doo scuba steve dude it's it's a
horror series and we would be remiss not
to shout you out because i think you are
probably pound for pound a more
experienced and learned horror fan than
either of us
combined the amount of horror films you
have seen i'm not just talking about
mainstream stuff made by recognizable
nay i feel like you will watch anything
in the horror genre you watch the
straight to video [ __ ] you watch the
streaming stuff and then occasionally
you pop up you know with like a
conjuring or whatever most of feel like
most of the recommendations you've sent
me are obscure and strange and things
where i would have never sought them out
on my own so scoobs
maintain that credibility and uh
you know maybe when it's time for you to
shuffle off the mortal coil you can
voodoo transfer your own soul into the
doll of somebody and then send it to us
and we can keep you uh here forever
can we start over
oh sure what would you have in mind
scuba steve scuba
[Music]
you